luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel i'm here with my whole family
and my sister here and we
are in isla murada in the florida keys
and we are going fishing for invasive
lying fish we're gonna go spear fishing
in fact and we're going to catch clean
and cook up what we catch
good morning morning good morning
welcome to the key yeah luke jeff good
morning jeff good to meet you yeah you
got it excellent
all right here we are with forever young
spear fishing i've got captain jeff and
i've got tony young here and they are
going to take us out snorkeling and
looking for lionfish hey thomas you
excited
i haven't been spearfishing underwater
since i was a teenager and i absolutely
love it so i'm excited to get a chance
to do this again and i've always wanted
to spear lionfish so this is this is
gonna be cool
[Music]
oh my goodness look how clear that is
oh look i can see fish right there see
we thought this would be the perfect
spot for you guys to hop in get your
gills wet i'm about to jack up the light
exposure on my list
time to get the lady views
and this is how you lose 1.5 million
subscribers right now because we're in a
special protected area only certain
permit holders can spare invasive
lionfish and that includes mr young so
if we see any lionfish here he's gonna
spear him but after we go and snorkel
around here let the kids have some fun
we're gonna go try some other places
where i can get a chance to spear some
lionfish
yeah this is how we this is how we catch
the fish we stick your diaper down in
the reef and all the fish float to the
top
all right guys you ready
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you want to see a cleaner fish cleaning
a barracuda like six of them
whoa watch out for you have fun yeah i
swam with them i literally got close to
them and they didn't attack me they were
like
hello
hey jacob did you have fun yeah
nathan do you need a pee yeah you know
how you pee in a wetsuit hell you just
pee your pants you ain't cool
unless you pee your pants maybe you guys
need to go pee come on
everyone just beat their pants raise
your hand yay
i think it's time to go look for some
lionfish i want to go poke a fish tell
me you like the beanbag
so we had fun doing a little bit of
snorkeling now it's time to knuckle down
and do some serious lionfish hunting now
lionfish are an invasive species from
the indian pacific ocean area so they're
all over from southern japan to
australia to the philippines they've
been let loose here and they're just all
over they're an invasive species here in
the caribbean gulf of mexico area and
over in the mediterranean so we're going
to hunt the lionfish using these three
prong hawaiian spears and they're really
simple easy to use so even i might be
able to spear one
[Laughter]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
awesome
[Music]
are you sad to be leaving this spot
yeah she will go to a new spot
[Music]
that's
okay
that's so cool
[Applause]
so
oh
i miss
well i missed my first lionfish all
right we're just gonna go try another
spot go try to poke another fish
oh
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
oh my goodness okay i dubbed down there
and i nicked him and he took off to a
separate coral head
and we're gonna see if we can't find him
over there luckily these things don't
run very far
i shot him again so we're gonna try to
get him
[Music]
foreign
okay i shot him a third time we got him
on the prongs but you need to really
work him out of that hole and it's just
too hard so mr young is going to go down
there try to get him out of that hole
[Music]
woohoo
[Music]
there he is got about six bullet holes
in him
and his spine's right there oh yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
so
um
whoa nice shot
oh what a great trip even though we only
got two fish i'm super jazzed because
normally they do this with scuba gear
it's a real challenge to to get this
snorkeling but we did it
oh i appreciate that thank you so much
that was such a great time what was your
favorite thing you saw
fish
[Music]
i got to tell you the bottom looks
really far away when you're up there at
30 feet of water you're like dad you're
like oh wow
doing everything you can decide we
caught the lionfish now we're going to
show you how to clean them these are a
venomous fish if you get stung by their
venomous spines it hurts like a bee on
steroids from what i hear it doesn't
feel good so not in there yeah so
there's no spines here no spines there
do have one you can see right there
they've got oh i see they got right like
a catfish right there and then a couple
on the anal fin okay and then everything
up on their door so all the dorsal fins
when you get stuck and that flush gets
pulled back the grooves are exposed and
the venom is able to leave the spine
gotcha so the longer the spine and the
farther it goes in the more venom can
get into your system you ever been
spined i have been stuck a couple
how bad was it uh for me it's usually
not too bad i might have built up a
tolerance over time but for most people
you know if you get in your finger the
whole hand will swell up about twice the
size
oh hey manatee that's our buddy steve hi
steve he uh he now eats lionfish
carcasses
it's a flesh-eating manatee
oh that's so hardcore steve oh and
there's a nurse shark right there so
they all know our boat they're ready for
their dinner to fillet these what i do
is i just pull their pectoral fin back
make a cut there
and then i'll hold the entire body of
the fish using just the tip of the knife
going very slow and careful so you can
see that whole time i'm just basically
keeping my hand in the same position
yeah
trying not to move very much and that's
oh that looks gorgeous that's the prized
meat that's why lionfish is so delicious
and his skin's not too bad looks like
you can probably just fry it up and eat
the skin you can yeah
one piece hold on
look at that
oh there he goes there he goes oh he
just ate
he just ate it that manatee just ate
fish flesh so he'll eat his spines at
all like um you know they kind of it
just seems like they kind of chew on i
don't know if they're getting like the
moisture out of the fish or what they
are but
they seem to play with it for quite a
while
nice and tight okay all right now drop
it right right in front of steve
bless leaving manatee
oh he's just totally sucking that down
[Music]
steve you're my favorite manatee ever
man
thank you very much you're welcome
you're right thank you thank you it ate
a ton of meat but there you go some
little teeny tiny lionfish fillets and
we're going to take these home and cook
them up is this a shirt yeah
yeah you like that it says forever young
spear fishing
we had such a blast this is one of the
best trips i've had in a long time i
really appreciate it yeah it was an
amazing trip thank you so much for
coming out with us listen if you guys
are in the florida keys and you want to
do spear fishing snorkeling scuba diving
rod and reel fishing whatever check out
forever young charters with tony and
jeff here and they will hook you up guys
i'm going to put links down in the video
description below their website and
social media accounts so check that out
thank you thank you great having you
guys oh we had such a great time after
swimming in the salt water and all the
hot sun ice cream sounded like the
perfect thing becca got key lime sorbet
and then melanie got a slice of key lime
pie
dipped in chocolate frozen on a stick
that hit the spot
way down
hey good morning guys
oh
i am walking gently i am walking
gingerly but i am walking
oh
oh
i'm gonna get some stuff to cook up that
lionfish and i'm gonna get a little
extra seafood to go with it and we are
gonna have a wonderful seafood lunch
today all right we got island seafood
market near pine island here and it
really backs up right to the marina
oh good fresh seafood
hey becca i've got something for you
who's got two thumbs and loves key lime
pie
this lady all right while the kids are
doing online school i'm gonna cook up
some lionfish and some jumbo shrimp and
some lane snapper and conch fritters
it's we're gonna have a great lunch here
i'm gonna show you some cool recipes
we got some naked mango juice this
stuff's nice and thick and we're gonna
reduce it in a pot until it becomes a
wicked awesome mango sauce
[Music]
okay
that's why tonight
[Music]
all right that's it
all right we'll just cool that sauce
down it'll be ready in just a few
minutes
[Music]
yes
there's the lane snapper
coconut crusted lionfish and some prawns
looking nice good
it's a lionfish here
mango sauce here
and we're just gonna go and
drizzle that on the coconut crusted fish
and shrimp
with the lane snapper i fried it on the
bottom then finished it off in the oven
and it gives it that nice crunchy
texture on the bottom without making it
too heavy and greasy if you fry the
whole thing good
really good oh the conch footage with
mango chutney is good
would you rather try some of the
lionfish
melanie what do you think of the
lionfish oh it's really good it's all
good thanks for watching guys we hope
you enjoyed this video as much as we
enjoyed filming it if you want to see
more videos from the outdoor voice
youtube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
saturday morning and don't forget to
check out our many playlists whether
it's camping travel and adventure or
catch and cook videos thanks for
watching if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
youtube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every saturday
morning and hit that bell button you'll
get notifications thanks for watching
becca's living her best life here really
good